good
morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning toast I can't believe it came it
went it happened cam to us to is in the
books
I am broken like my by we're not the
same people that you saw the last time
on the show no not emotionally mentally
and physically we've changed no
physically for sure because I'm so sore
and I was trying to figure out what I
was so sore from and I think it was the
tubing because you're holding on for
dear life on the tube up behind a jet
ski like just cuz you don't want to fall
off and I was using every muscle in my
body muscles I haven't used since I was
a child and I literally couldn't like
wake up this morning because literally
the act of physically getting up made my
muscles ache for me it's my neck and
it's from here never broke my heart and
hongseong Highway and it's crazy that if
I hadn't like lost my mind during those
two songs I would have maybe been ok but
like my necks will do that to you my
neck is broken
I feel like Zoolander it's crazy I like
Luke combs his music turned me into a
rock head like those are probably not
two things you hear every day ya know it
was it was so let we are going to do an
entire camp toast eleganza he's all
campus we were looking page 6e news her
stories and everything pales in
comparison I couldn't agree with a key
I'm toast we're gonna recap it we have
five stories from camp we're gonna do
questions at the end so if you're on the
YouTube stream feel free to drop a
question I got so many questions last
night that I felt like compelled to do a
Q&A because like people were like either
so confused like people who like kind of
know what the toast is like people just
from my Instagram and then there were
most people who were just like such FOMA
like had a million questions yeah about
like what it was how to get there
they're like you have to be invited I'm
like no I was shelling tickets I was
about to say what was the most annoying
question that you got cuz the one that I
get that so annoying is how do you get
invited like yeah as if we're not
pimping it out all year likes true you
know yeah
but it was just such a great weekend I
mean I really thought like nothing could
even come close to camp toast one
because camp this one was so special it
was special it was intimate and it was
rainy so we spent so much time together
and it made it incredibly special and I
was like nervous because we went from 80
to 250 people and I'm like it's gonna be
a [ __ ] show and and it was a [ __ ] show
in the best way and like the amount of
people was the perfect amount like we
were
the Kim can technically hold 650 I don't
think we would ever do success feels
like people sleeping in every corner of
the camp I say next year 300 and never
more nothing less
it didn't feel like that many people
like when I look at pictures it looks
like wow so many people but I feel like
I got to talk to everyone at least once
I know I knew everyone's face it was a
great amount of people because it was
like I knew so many faces but every time
I did something I also was meeting new
faces and that's what they use to say
about cloning it's a great place because
you feel like you know everyone but
every day you meet someone new so that
was the best amount of people there were
still some people I wish I got to spend
more time with but you know camps what
should make it they were busy doing
their own thing right and that's what I
loved it's like when you think about
camps I can't was so great but it was
really like prison like you had to be at
this place at a certain time and you
couldn't do this and you couldn't do
that and it was fun but it was really
like had a lot of rules and I think
people on the first day we're like a
little confused because they're used to
going to camp or like school where it's
like you do this at a certain time and
we were like here's a schedule use it
loosely you want to go out to the gas
station get a snack we don't care you
want to go lay at the pool while
everyone else it's camp is what you make
it to schedules like you make it but
here are a list of activities that will
be going on in case you want to do that
you want to sleep through breakfast cool
you want to move your bunk cool yeah
Miranda um Earhart slept till one
o'clock and her husband was looking for
her oh my god I'm crying that's I'm
jealous there were so many like
malarious drunk moments like Lauren
Elizabeth temple fell asleep on the
grass I saw and then Shimon I taken a
picture of her and was really talking
blurry but she used to check yellow and
it came out as a premium photo the grass
looks really great it looks like
editorials she said oh my gosh just like
so many funny like a little moments like
that that were just big made camp what
it was oh man it was it was incredible
we're gonna walk you through it with the
fast five stories that you need to know
from camp toast I think that okay I
think we got okay
first night was the Welcome Party which
you know it was enough cheese and
crackers for eight people it was enough
cheese and enough wine to get these
girls turn confetti wine sponsored our
Welcome Party
not only that they sought sponsored the
party with their wine which everyone
loved they had a better white a rose a
Pinot Grigio ma but they don't go mad
anyhow I mean camper loved they also
brought this photo photobooth it was
like a 360 kind of like the e glam cam
and I think that first like when they
were setting up
we're like what is this and then one
person went in and it was literally the
most premium photobooth I've ever seen
in my life like the most amazing light
suppose it had a GoPro it was moving
around it was swivelling it was motion
it was a jiff it was a video it was so
[ __ ] cool like I went in 100 times
people were getting so creative
throughout the night I liked ways to
make the 5 seconds matter
it was so premium so we can't think
confetti want enough for a sponsoring
and letting us know about this premium
you want that you could find at your
local liquor store and be bringing in
the most premium content generator there
is like we all looks like sweaty campers
but then you go into the toe spot 360
and you look like you're at the Grammys
yeah who was the most creative would you
say me in the photo booth me really yeah
really
me and my jewel did you fit three
campers in no that was really good it
was good the Italian American and French
camper got together in the spirit of
camp and they did the photo book
together inspecting premium and it's
like my best part I was like was it I
wasn't sure if I was gonna post it to my
Instagram because you know you can't put
a preset on a video also by the way I
feel like we feel like we have to
recover like fast cuz we've to get into
the past five there's no back side so we
need to know but there's just so much
camp to recap Thanks um I was like maybe
I won't post the video because I can't
preset it'll kind of just hurt my flow
people won't get it who even like people
hate the campers no they don't it was my
best performing by far and away it's had
a hundred thousand views I had a very
low engagement for camp to us use did
yeah that's surprised I know my feet is
almost like too green I think the
hashtag cam toast was like so poppin
because everyone was like making their
user-generated content and I just fell
to the wayside but you know what I'm
happy about ya know everyone got such
premium content and like that's the
thing about cam toes it's like everyone
there it's like we met on the Internet
we know how this thing works everyone's
taking pictures of each other
there's no judgement they will work with
you until you've got the shot if you
don't have the Jackie O flow preset
someone else will preset it for you then
put it in the toast to get out the car
in the back and it's just it's a whole
system and like everyone there really
supports each other in the most
important way it's not just like
cheering you on when you can't do the
climbing center thing which by the way
is so important and the people who
worked at the Pocono Valley the staff
they were like everyone here is so nice
to each other when other schools and
stuff come here they like bull each
other they're like you [ __ ] Busey
everyone at cam to us it's like whether
you do it or not
you're getting a standing ovation the
Welcome Party was really just a hit and
it was just that like a Welcome Party
everyone came around five o'clock we had
dinner we get drinks then we got [ __ ]
lit so after dinner and dinner was so
delicious the food at camp is
surprisingly so good like Ben's like are
you dying that you need a meal I'm like
no honestly like I never ate so good in
my life
no there was many a carving station
night one and it was creamy and there
was a freezer set up in the dining hall
for three days straight filled with
cheap witches and that is just how you
know that like this was a camp that I
procured you know right it was so
delicious the Welcome Party was just
such a smash stuffed potato it was a
potatoes stuffed with more tater
it was so good I forgot about that so
good and the party just went on all
night we had that with flip Cup games we
had the photo booths we had the bar open
we had a campfire we had s'mores we had
a guitar player s'mores and we
eventually fire everything really it's
so funny like we can set up all we want
like fancy evening activities at the end
of the day it always ends up just being
karaoke with a microphone and an iPad
and a speaker yeah that's all you need
to have a good time I can't test it's so
true like music makes the world go
around the Welcome Party was just like
so lit and it really was what we needed
to just like catapult this group of
strangers into family you know ya know
everyone really turned him I would say
that was the most turn tonight led to me
me to UM that's who I procured this
bruise on my leg I fell over one of the
campfire logs because was dark and I was
in a rush yeah we rushed into it I don't
know I was just talking quickly you know
and like it was just nothing's worse
than falling but they know there's
absolutely nothing worse when everyone's
like yeah I'm like I think we're just
trying to call I just wanted everyone to
pretend like they didn't see it right
and that's what like that's the nice
thing to do
yeah then you look like an [ __ ] who
doesn't care about the news just so you
know you ever see me fall just pretend
like you didn't see it that's all I need
anyways but now I have this nice boobs
just bruised to take with me to Colgate
reunion which is camp toast part two so
Peverley wells to turn up at the Welcome
Party everyone was in desperate need of
liquid IV because we were hungover as
hell so many people brought their liquid
ID we had our cam toast water bottles
and to just merge together for a perfect
merger and acquisition liquid IV is the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated try and drink more water liquid
IV hydrates you two to three times
faster and it's more efficient than
water alone with an added bonus of
vitamin C b3 b5 b6 and b12
all of like what IVs products you
cellular transport technology ctt a
specific ratio of glucose sodium and
potassium when mixed with 16-ounce water
it helps your body absorb more of the
water and nutrients you drink directly
into your bloodstream so after a night
of drinking it's literally the most
premium thing you can get out there and
they come a convenient TSA friendly
powder packets for travel helps prevent
jet lag and altitude sickness so if you
flew for the last car you flew from
Hawaii damn toast you got you're like
what I'd be on the plane thanks to look
whatever we love liquid IV we know you
will too right now our listeners will
get 25% off at liquid IV calm and use
our code toast at checkout that's 25%
off anything you order on liquid IVs
website so go to liquid I be calm enter
our promo code toast to get your savings
and start getting better hydration
that's liquid IV dot-com promo code
toast
don't wait start properly hydrating
today yeah you've had to start properly
hydrating yesterday if you worry cam
toaster yeah so when we woke up on
Saturday we were like oh damn like
everyone's gonna be dead and broken
we're gonna show up to breakfast no
one's gonna be there uh-huh nope but
these toasters turn up and turn out
breakfast starts at 9:30 then as 10:30
we all convene in the rec hall but it
was a Saturday so we didn't do an
episode of the morning toast we did
games also we didn't have sort of the
morning toaster and it just felt like
that's not really what people wanted I
was trying to read the room I hate like
making things about me when no one like
wants to be made it about me personally
I don't want to talk about celebrities
when like we're at the most iconic event
of the year like I don't mean I only
want to talk about what's going on right
here and that's exactly what we did we
played a game it's like it more like an
icebreaker game called the mostest where
we split up everyone into like ten
groups with different bunks so they got
to meet new people and the game was
called the mostest and basically we did
a bunch of rounds and every round each
group was responsible for sending up one
representative who had the mostest
something so the first part was like
send ups the person in your group with
the mostess leg hair and then we had
like the 15 representatives and we would
judge whose leg hair was this it was
unfair because there were some boys and
also like Oh every girl like shave their
legs except for me
but haters one the most disliked hair by
a mile we also got the most vegetable
and we had truly it was such a turnout
we had a tie and the man to let the
audience decide because they went to a
tiebreaker it was [ __ ] wild Eve
honestly turned into a strip show which
I adored oh that's also what everything
I camp those turns
just a new different work off at work
off um that game was actually really fun
in like a great way to get to know one
another but I could have fun raunchy way
and to know what people's talents are
like who can sing who can be right well
we did by the way everyone at camp toast
can do the splits except for me where's
the worlds where did I go wrong in my
life that I never learned how they
properly this one he did gymnastics like
our whole life and I'm not not flexible
like my high kicks were high you really
can't do it no and I've never been able
to work so like I just want to know what
what happened maybe it's a it's
definitely a Jewish thing we spent like
an hour hour and a half just really
getting to know one another you know
finding out more about each other that
was really fun
and it was just a good time then we
lunch no we gave out color war positions
and team so we split up the group
completely randomly into half pink half
green I love how everyone just came so
prepared for either team with pink face
paint pink clothing pink beads pink band
down I was like they had [ __ ]
everything it was so premium like I
thought people would have to like run
out to like the local Target and get
something no everyone just like had
stuff on them and we gave them time
before lunch like prep get to know their
teammates we gave our positions to new
toasters who we thought executed good
leadership qualities had a loud voice
and some old og toasters as well and I
think we made some great choices
max Davenport precious gem of a man well
we dream do some shout outs later cuz we
also be about someone boards Sofia sino
wonderful general I loved the scene Oh
sisters they were sisters on the stream
they were four sisters so just like I'm
four sisters loved four sisters and like
I feel like if we had come to camp to us
as patrons like maybe we would have just
only hung out with each other you know
but the see knows really had roots they
they spread their seed and they spoke
with other and they did town show with
the other girls and they weren't like
clicky sisters like maybe we went have
been they spread their roots roots so
far and wide that it wasn't until the
last night that I found out which four
of them were the sisters because they
were all with different people the
entire time and I didn't even know the
which four were the seen us you know
it's like this is Latino everyone really
like gave it their all
latitude wise you know and like really
stepped out of their comfort zone so
many people came out of themselves and
that's probably the number one question
that I got there like not a lot of my
friends are toasters like I really
wanted to go this year but I chickened
out so I would have had to go alone like
did anyone come alone and I did to say
that I think just as many
came alone as people who came with like
family I agree and I think the people
who came alone like now they would never
come with a friend because like they it
forces you out of your shell obviously
but you have such an epic time because
of it like meeting new people where it's
it's definitely a lot safer to come with
a friend and you know you'll have a
guaranteed good time and a buddy
but you've never had that experience of
like oh my god I'm totally on my own
like what do I do for this camp also
like knowing that most other people come
by themselves it makes it a lot less
scary because like if everyone's scared
then nothing scary you know and some of
the most epic campers are the ones who
came by themselves yes did can't come by
yourself
Oh totally totally I mean she is like so
bubbly and like effervescent that
there's no way of knowing but I think
there's no way I think that she did -
we'll talk about that in a second she
was the overall MVP of camp the position
that was held by her name McCurry last
year so those were some big shoes to
fill and boy did she fill them ok so
then everyone ate lunch and at lunch
time was when the bar opened and when
the merchants are open so we made
special camp toast merits a lot of TyTy
some tank tops and t-shirts and
sweatshirts of luggage tags pop sockets
the usual a lot inspired by Kanye West
you know as a cult we look up to his
cult
yeah we were inspired by his merch but
not his price point no no no not at all
so don't worry and merch will be
available to the public on Thursday
night we just want to make sure all of
our camp toasters get their merch first
and then we will release to the public
so stay tuned for that also luggage tags
there's a morning to us all good shag
that is obviously premium premium but
what you don't see is on the back it
says what's right back for the scamp
which is a question that really you know
sounded like reverb rated through camp I
still don't know I still don't know I
think I packed well at the end of the
day all I wore was workout clothes and
merch I don't think I would do it again
but then I was looking at some toasters
who were dressed so [ __ ] cute and I
was like jealous because I didn't pack
one romper I mean Liz height was just
like slaying slaying this camp and I
just looked like a dirty dishrag you
know I was really thankful for the merch
because it like clothes to me for four
years no same same thing so then okay so
lunch was everyone was like already in
there their garb they were making up
Cheers
color war started at precisely two
o'clock on the upper fields with a game
of capture the flag and it's not your
typical capture the flag it's our camp
version of capture the flag
which is more fun because
takes place on a field like everyone can
watch in chairs plus I'm running all
over camp like looking for a flag I
don't know how regular capture the flag
well me neither the one that sets come
in so he's talking out on the OC I don't
know which game he yeah but are you sure
he wasn't R the R version is different
and really fun and like it comes in like
little rounds so everyone gets to play
everyone if you wanted to play or not
the thing that I really likes about
color Wars like everyone got so involved
like and it wasn't mandatory like I'm
sure there was like a couple people who
didn't like put on clothes like we're
hanging out by the pool and like good
for them like but everyone really showed
up like in their garb they were
screaming cheering make up dances doing
cheerleading stunts we had two halftime
shows by each team that are completely
filmed we were obviously doing a whole
patreon recap video we have premium
contract for the weekend so if you want
to see your team's cheer you can see it
there it was Suns I was getting so
nervous at every turn I was also being
like a grandmother like get down from
there but you know it they they were
great we had some cheerleaders in the
crowd we had uh Chloe she was like an
actual professional - yeah you could sit
you could tell you could she taught
everyone some moves color word was
honestly so fun like we were just on the
field everyone was so like drinking you
know rose' from their water bottles and
also being incredibly athletic and it's
like get you a toaster who can do both
no totally and then we had pretty like I
would say maybe the most epic game of
tug of war and tug of war is like fun
because I mean it's annoying because
like the excitement happens so quickly
and then you've like set up again it
takes just as long to set up as it does
but it was literally the most intense
rounds of target where that were lasting
so long like when you thought the pink
team had it the green team got it like
yeah it was really that kept me on my
feet and as the person who was I'm
holding the bandana in the middle and my
procuring the the round it was [ __ ]
scary to be like in the presence of
these girls who were like ready to
[ __ ] die for this rope and and they
did they went and and it was such a
fierce competition and a really close
battle to the end yeah and it really
came down to the spirit points yeah
because the Green Team one color
captured the flag the pink team won
tug-of-war and so then it was up to
spirit and the pink I mean they were
both incredible the pink team just edged
act out that win yeah they were more
spirited but they were also like a
little bit more organizing their spirit
like which I really appreciate it as a
person who appreciates organization and
who will also appreciate I can believe
it's taken us 20 minutes to talk about
him was dr. Theodore for chairman who
was a judge of Kyle
or and also the most precious gem of a
man throughout the entire weekend like I
don't know how he ever did campus
without him we will never be doing it
without him ever again
no no one had a better weekend no one
had a better weekend but also no one was
[ __ ] better behaved like he I was
really nervous about bringing him
because it's like such a big camp and
it's like a lot it's overwhelming and
like everyone loves Theo and I didn't
want him to feel overwhelmed and also
like I didn't want to feel overwhelmed
myself like I'm trying to engage in my
community and I'm like out here like
picking up feel [ __ ] you know like was
it gonna be annoying and I have to say
it was maybe the best decision I ever
made he behaved so well he went to the
bathroom like clockwork like didn't make
me wait for him like and everyone like
we all the sisters came but also our
friends Kristen and Mario came like they
were so helpful there were two other
dogs at camp that hung out in the office
like when we had meals and stuff Theo
would be in the office with his camp
friends like that yeah it was so it was
really just perfect everyone like really
helped in taking care of him but he also
took care of himself and it was the best
decision I ever made we had the best
weekend like Ben came home last night
from this wedding in Miami and I was
like Theo like didn't even look at him I
was like Theo don't know it's it's camp
friends or bust yeah cuz now you and
Theo are camp friends and pens just his
home friend and exactly home friends our
lame school hasn't started yet I'm not
talking to you exactly Oh [ __ ] Theo
okay then after color war came what I
think was Claudia's favorite favorite
part of the weekend it was wet Republic
it was wet Republic boot party like it
was a four o'clock
everyone was sweaty from color where we
thought they want some downtime before
dinner maybe you get a tan relax I
didn't know it was gonna turn into
literally Encore Beach Club yeah because
it was Vegas like I was living around I
was like look what I did like I made a
[ __ ] Vegas pool party like everyone
was just drinking and I thought
everyone's gonna be drinking and I gotta
pull float relax no it started we got so
many cute pool floats were like people
take pictures go for a dip you know KB's
hi it was an Olympic sized pool and we
didn't know how many pool floats would
fill it up but we got like a bunch of
really big ones we got 20 and I was like
oh my god that's crazy and the staff at
the camp helped us blow them up like
before everyone got there and we stored
them in the office like you couldn't
walk one foot in the office like the
bathroom in the office was unusable for
a day like it was really so big and I
was like I'm crazy we throw them in the
pool literally it was one float like it
looked so terrible I'm so sorry like
next year we're saving these ones but
next time we need 20 more at least a
hundred percent but then there was also
space for people to swim and get
and dirty which they did with DJ buddy
and it was just like DJ buddy is
somebody we use for I mean the DJ we
used for the whole weekend he's just
like a local guy and he's now a famous
person because he's a famous toe sucking
lived for him he was wild he was wild oh
my god it was just like so everything at
campus just turns into like the most
extra thing ever and we're literally do
all like on a grind line doing the
wobble at the edge of the pool and I
think if anyone's gonna fall into the
pool like it's me no one was closer to
the edge but I didn't we just like all
got turned up was like everyone's in the
Cabana with their pool floats and their
drinks from there more and oh by the way
and everyone brought the most premium
clothing like it was like the they made
customer shows for chow
Dallas toasters everywhere they showed
up these Gruber girls who came together
we're in a matching outfit even their
pajamas were matching people came with
customers they made their own merch they
made their own water bottles they made
their everyone had a palm leaf bathing
suit palm leaf kimono palm leaves
something from Target Renee made her own
jewels c'n that was toasting we need to
make that it for our next March drop
yeah here's what we need to make for our
next merge drop that I found out this
weekend I can't chose some sort of jewel
accessory with toasty vibes on it some
sort of dog accessory because cat who
won MVP this year she brought me a
harness and a leash that were morning
toast Brandon like everyone was asking
me about it well yo was rocking them all
weekend so the official model that's a
must
that's a mess I had some other ideas I
can't remember them right now Anna and
and we'll get to it okay okay everyone's
like really showed up and showed up
decked out in their toasty merch whether
it was from Amazon or it was literally
hand sewed by their mom like no it was
still premium it was so premium
and that pool party just emotion of all
the twisty dives it was really like the
biggest day drinking day the bar is open
from 12 to 12 every single day and just
a shout out to Frogtown Chop House who
helped serve all of the confetti or
local catering company last year and
this year they're so [ __ ] good at
their job that like we never talk to
them they just like do everything like
camp trust is a lot of work it is a big
event to put on like people don't
understand that undertaking of putting
together not only it can't put a
four-day all-day event it's a lot Bailey
mcfarland couldn't do it right so like
ja Rule couldn't do I have the most
important part the alcohol be completely
covered like these guys like we saw them
to the first day we saw them the last
day
there was no problem there was no
problem and they were so cute like
flirty with all the girls like everyone
loved them like it was so great and like
everyone was served and over-served and
you know they don't judge nobody got cut
off I don't think even one of the
bartender's on the last day I was
talking to him he was like I got off my
shift at 4 o'clock and I came back for
the town show he was like it was the
most incredible thing I've ever seen in
my life he was there all night I'm
pretty sure you have double haters
yeah like they it was just the vibe was
so like tangible you know so and
everyone who was like there either to be
there or to work like was just happy to
be there and like that makes everyone
else happy and they were also just like
in awe of like this toasty vibes like
they didn't get it but like they
appreciated it yes I think that I think
we've turned some of them into podcast
listeners just so that they're like
understanding why what they're doing
here and people keep asking me they're
like you should do like regional ones
like have come to talas and like I look
I think if we did like franchise in and
do like a couple a year like maybe one
in Dallas one on the west coast like it
could work but there's something about
this specific campground one because
it's like so close to our heart it is
where we actually went to camp um that
makes it so special that like guess it's
a good idea like I know maybe we could
do it but I have really no interest I it
just wouldn't be the same like even when
we had that day by climbing Center ropes
course waterfront it's all activities
have you grew up doing as kids so I
remember the first time that I didn't I
can tell you what you know what level of
skill you need or how nervous you should
be idler or like when people are asking
just questions of where to go and what
to do we don't know at another
campground that we don't know like we
just don't know and it just wouldn't be
the same like there's so much heart and
soul in this place and like all the
memories for us and also our experience
there that we're actually able to speak
on it if we just chose a campground off
of a website online like we it could be
fire festival like we always knew we're
at PVR like it would never be fire
festival because like we know the
grounds like we know they know how to do
their job and like they throw events
double this size every week right we
know like the photos what they actually
better in person
you know campgrounds like that's what we
were setting the whole time the vistas
the [ __ ] miss says man it's the most
beautiful campground and like you didn't
appreciate it as a kid as it could it's
just grass for you to roll around it but
as an adult lives in the city who never
gets to see grass like I really got to
appreciate the nature of it this time
like I just found myself looking around
at the lake and the mountains behind and
the trees and the grass just being like
wow nature is beautiful trail is so
beautiful I just want to give a shout
out to our previous 11:11 way
and just to the man upstairs himself and
mother nature because the weather this
weekend was so incredible especially
from last year where it rained all day
every day every night everything like we
couldn't do anything without a [ __ ]
raining and cam just like oh my god like
everything just was so much more
heightened because of the beautiful
weather and the vistas and the views so
even when they were just having downtime
or just it's a magical surrounding and
like for Fairweather it rained once
Saturday night at midnight when it was
really time for everyone to go to bed
after they've been drinking through
color war through the pool party through
dinner through the carnival through the
evening activity he started to rain and
I wasn't even upset I'm like this is for
the best
yeah this is for the best of course I
didn't stop anyone then I see videos of
like everyone who gave these girls
pictures I don't know I saw people with
pictures of full beers I guess if beers
like that makes sense you can distribute
it better but I was like I thought
weren't suppose to be there like how'd
they get pictures no totally anyways so
after the pool party then obviously we
had dinner shower our shower is my
favorite part it was just like you know
you see this bunk this little shitty
bunk you're like what I'm gonna sleep
here but then you come to just like love
your bunk so much especially like I
invested in good sheets egg crates and
blankets this time and it made the
biggest difference like I had the best
sleeps of my life it was so quiet we
such incredibly well cat also brought us
face masks for sleeping that I used
every single night and I also took CBD
every night and it really made a huge
difference in a my hangover and be my
quality of sleep you know what I took it
and I realize I never have a problem
sleeping and it was the worst sleep I
ever had I don't know I don't know what
went wrong I maybe I'll have to try it
again
um oh so we had a totally full bunk
since we brought all of our friends and
like we had our shower our rail blinding
up to shower like I was literally like
depressed when I got home last night
because and thank you were alone they
used to happen to me when I when I was
at camp for two months and like my bunk
mates were like my best friends you're
never alone like you're used to waking
up with people around you doing
everything with people around you that
like when you we at home like for a few
weeks after camp I used to be in like a
like a slump like a real depression and
last night I was so bored
litora cos Ben hadn't come home yet like
facetiming everyone I knew like asked
them like what they were doing like I
was so bored and it's it's that same
camp slump yes hope what's craziest so
our true friends that came Margo Lewin
and Kristen or maybe
just tell anyone who thinks it's crazy
are two of our best friends from camp
but from different camps margot loons my
best friend we started going to camp
together in 2000 and we've been best
best friends ever since even when like
we were too young to like have a phone
and talk to each other we figured out
how to say so close she lives in the
city we lived in Long Island and you're
her mom and your mom wouldn't meet your
mom our mom wouldn't meet in the middle
of the highway like halfway from the
city to Long Island you would like to
swap pick each other up like Parent Trap
I'd take the rest oh yeah like we
figured out how to say best friends it's
now 20 years later and we're camping
together again and then Kristen's our
best friend from when we went to see
Petey in the 2005 yes but like they Nick
now we're all camp restroom it's like
both of our camp friends coming together
Kristen like obviously went to camp with
us there but Margot had never been to
those grounds and we kept trying to get
her to admit that okay yeah no it's true
like and you know what I was so glad
that we that they came because like like
it was a a good tech hot and I'm not a
good what's the word it was like I
wasn't sure it was I was sure if I was
like working or partying you know and I
would get like wasting to be like wait
I'm working you know so like having them
there really made it more of like a
party for me well yeah sometimes like
just like getting things arranged like I
was working you know like setting up
events for people like using the hashtag
and the sponsor had hashtag ad but like
they really made it like more of a party
you know no totally so we'll definitely
be pairing friends again next year we
had our carnival on Saturday night which
was so fun at first I was like just
playing the music I was like I'm not
gonna get too involved we had a ton of
inflatables like we human foosball
we had an obstacle course we had this
wild [ __ ] circular thing it was
honestly so much fun that was the most
physical I got after foosball I couldn't
breathe that circle thing was the
hardest I ever laughs in my life I did
it with concerts because I saw a video
I'm like okay this looks like decent
this will be test my everyone was
standing on a podium in a circle so it's
a circle of like six podiums people are
standing on and then this like two
sticks there to rubber come out and they
just circle round you have to either
jump or duck for yeah for the short one
you would have to jump over it back onto
your podium and for the tall one you'd
have to duck under your podium so the
short one comes around twice and I
jumped over it successfully and it was
crazy then of course I got hit and like
it went down I sell them
and I was like so scared after that I
hid in the corner of the entire time
watching bodies drop around me and I was
laughing he was gonna throw so hard I
was literally crying my thing like my
stomach hurt from hurt more than my
knees from laughing it's just the
carnival was so fun oh they also had and
I've seen this but I've never done it
we're like you put yourself in this like
bubble and you just like hit against
each other yeah I thought when they
didn't on The Bachelor chasing Jojo oh
my god I couldn't [ __ ] breathe I
don't even know who the toaster was
because I couldn't see inside I was
[ __ ] beating the [ __ ] out of her like
we were going at each other and I
couldn't you know it's like when you're
laughing so hard that you can breathe
but you have this talk because I wanted
to stop like I was dying and I couldn't
breathe like she kept knocking me down
it was so funny like that is what we set
out to do it was like that pure
unadulterated like happy fun that you
used to do when you were a kid and like
no one gets to do anymore lights like
when I was like on the ground and this
rubber ball like hysterically laughing
I'm like this is what camp was supposed
to be no and I was in charge of music I
just kept playing holily and nights over
and over again because if you haven't
listened to it yeah you have to but like
they were really the Hallelujah nights
and they were the best days of our lives
like when we are old and gray we will be
looking back on camp toasts and that's
will be our fondest memories yeah and
like that's that's like what camp is
like I really look back on my time and
at real summer camp like with the most
fondest of memories I feel like I really
like grew into myself there I like got
really confident there like I just loved
camp so much and it's so crazy to me
that like it's just a lifestyle thing
like not a lot of people go to camp or
went to camp as a kid it's I think like
an East Coast thing so I'm just really
glad that we're getting to give that
experience to other people like that's
the best part
yeah and it's just like obviously we're
drinking but like there were on the last
day didn't drink at all and that was the
best thing the talent show I think
people thought I was blacked out I
hadn't had one sip of alcohol that day
it was just like the [ __ ] steamy
campy vibes had taken over and I was
possessed so Sunday rain Saturday at
midnight and that pretty much like
needed to put everyone to bed after
literally drinking since noon it's not
only like you're dead from the day but
like you have a whole nother day the day
starts at 9:00 right so you're dead from
the physical activity like that enough
would put me to bed at 11:00 but then
also to drinking and the excitement and
the pictures like it's so much like by
the time your head hits the pillow
you're [ __ ] dead but you also need to
get prepared for the next day like it's
not like it's just over right so then
final day I can't even say what my
favorite I was I think it might have
been the final day I think mine was
Saturday
we woke up did breakfast we went to the
rec hall we played another game called
the sing down of course the coasters are
so [ __ ] competitive and I was scared
to make a call right now that's why
Judge Theodore for 10 minutes the best
judge that was so funny so the sing down
is basically we've split up into the
groups again and we did rounds of like
coming up with a list of songs that all
have the same word so first we start off
easy with love like duh okay the ground
never end the round never ended then we
went much harder and we went to Sun s UN
and like that was much easier so if
someone couldn't if someone had a song
that like didn't really have the word
like they misused it or if they couldn't
think of anyone they would be China
so it was like literally my dream come
true we're having 300 people on the
right college being like China yeah it
was great and then we also did one with
toast and not really sure people up
snitch on the toast was so qualifier
yeah I mean obviously I was just waiting
for it everyone to be and here's a toast
to my real friends and they don't care
about that he said sure I all says
justice for used to love you but I go
ends Avani oh my god Kyle coffee was
truly he had what a camper he was this
fair d'amour he got his spirit stick I
mean he was such like an integral part
of camp like it wouldn't have been the
same with Kyle Coffee didn't attend you
know it wouldn't have been especially
the thing that wouldn't have been the
same no he was being so funny and
spirited and justice for Gwen Stefani
and councillor Kyle he was really upset
because like you couldn't win if you
were the only person in your group who
knew this song and that you were
teaching it everyone around you had a
sing like you needed to everyone needed
to not everyone but like a majority of
the group needed to know the song so he
pulled some Gwen Stefani song out of his
ass that I'd never heard and like was
trying to get everyone to sing it like
nobody knew when he was talking about
just what's gonna happen it was goodbye
Kyle so he got has Shh i ned and he was
really upset because he thinks Gwen
Stefani is an icon who doesn't get
enough justice and I couldn't disagree
work but you know what that's his crust
America yeah anyways then the second
half of the third day we did it was the
campus day we did all the climbing
center activities there was a jungle
climbing Center and waterfront so this
was my personal favorite day because I
just love the client activity I love cam
activities and I just love the climbing
center because I have some athletic
ability I do like to challenge myself
it's like skiing it's like doing
something that I wouldn't ordinarily
and getting out of my comfort zone a
little bit so first we did the high
Odyssey which was so crazy I saw girls
like it was really like a team-building
exercise because you need people to help
you through it in P policy is an
obstacle course like I think it's 180
feet in the air
expecting scary and it's an obstacle
course like so hi I'm at the end there's
a zip line so that's really fun but we
used to do that as campers so for me
that was a breeze then I really wanted
to do the rock wall because I wanted to
beat Aryan Lannister and piss off the
edge of the world so I go to do the rock
wall and it was it was really so hard
and I almost almost almost made it to
the top but it was just I'm really just
too short and I I reached for the next
one and I fell and I just came tumbling
down and and literally my forearms were
pulsing from using new muscles then you
did the Giant Swing yes how was that for
you it was [ __ ] terrifying and also
like the shame I felt cuz like the part
of the Giant Swing is like everyone has
to pull you up
and I was like feeling self-conscious
like no one's gonna be able to get my
big fat ass up in the air but you know
what they don't know well really small
we pulled you you didn't want to go any
higher was he up nope it was honestly
terrifying and I and it's like so they
basically pulled they released the rope
and you just [ __ ] go flying and it's
honestly terrifying and the harness is
like pulling your vagine like so tight
but like it's if then you're just like
then after like the initial like drop
you're just like in the air swinging 50
feet in the air like looking at this
beautiful Vista and this beautiful lake
and it's like that's the same always
comes back to the vistas oh and then
when you go down that road it always
comes back to the toast right and that's
really the thing the thing is nothing
yeah anyways then there was also another
jungle course that I had never done yet
which was exciting pretty once since we
got to camp it was on the other side of
the lake since the last time we were
there they built a whole new ropes
course so it's called the treetops
course and this one I thought the oddest
he was Real Housewives of Orange County
Vicki Gunvalson getting her hands tough
no this one this one was because this
one was shorter than the Odyssey but
there's 11 things to go through the
Odyssey is only four courses and it was
real and you're responsible for clipping
on and off year that's the serious but
then once you learn it you realize it's
actually not scary because there's no
situation where you're not clipped to
anything you kill you unclip and clip
and you would never be suspended I
thought oh my god these girls are
drinking like I was like we got to put
the kibosh but once I learned it I was
like
oh no into it really tense your test
your mental and physical abilities and
everyone is up there just cheering
there's like 11 people doing it at one
time just cheering each other on and
like I just I felt like such a champion
it's like the way you feel after you get
like a wax it's like I could do anything
so I just saw the incredible then there
was a new thing called the drop zone
where you climb up a tree using like
steps and then you just jump off and I
was like the one thing I don't like is
being like suspended up what to call
them when you jump and you're just um
free-falling
like that is I don't get it's real from
that at all like I don't like Heights
but you know I'll do what I need to do
so I wasn't gonna do the drop then like
Jamie and all of these girls Missy no
sisters were doing it and they were like
pre pressuring me but also just
encouraging me and I watched him too and
I was like oh that doesn't look so bad
so I [ __ ] did it
I climbed up that thing and I jumped off
and you know it wasn't it was just not
enough joy for all the pain yeah like
there was so much climbing and then like
it was almost like the jump wasn't a
freefall enough yeah like you're just
propelling down so but I was glad I did
it and then I did the zipline with
Margot Lewin and we held our phones and
we film each other which was just like
so brave how did we stop there's of the
water zipline like that goes all the way
across the lake it's beautiful and again
just another beautiful Vista and it's
like it's like not that scary it's just
like enjoyable after everything else I
did it was a [ __ ] walk in the park it
was a breeze generally I was just
sitting there catching a breeze I spent
literally so much time at the lake I
would say as a camper my least favorite
activity was the lake and as a grown-ass
adults a vert activity is that the lake
going to bang on behind a jet ski with
just new friends like okay so I went
with Margo once and then I went with
just two new campers and we were
screaming at the top of our lungs like
couldn't breathe like you try to
communicate you're going so fast like
you feel like you're gonna fall if
you're holding on to this little [ __ ]
rubber float for dear life and you're
just like literally like gleeful that's
what it's Glee do you see my videos
Kat of course gave me her waterproof
phone case to take tubing with me and I
have a whole video of me Margaux and
Christine tubing having just the
greatest time of our lives like it's
[ __ ] pure joy pure joy like I was
laughing so hard like I was trying to
stick it all like slow down but like
it's so like and you're getting so wet
like you don't care cuz like no one
gives a [ __ ] like about what you look
like you're just like happy to
I know so the worst-case scenario is
that you fly off and you're just in the
lake and like you're fine yeah no I
don't think anyone did but there's no
fear involved so it's really just joy
some girls took it nice and easy in the
lake and they went you know paddle
boarding they went canoeing kayaking
just really more like a peaceful Canyon
Ranch five yeah and then also it was
also an option just lay by the pool all
day which a lot of people didn't now I'm
seeing people right that they regret it
that they wish but there's always next
year there's always next year okay then
the final night oh it was so sad but it
was the halleluiah night and I think it
was the best I think overall activity of
the entire camp it was the talent show
and there was so much talent there was
just so much encouragement Seanie vibes
cheering dancing laughing singing like
it was just incredible like the roof was
gonna burst off right look I would have
said like you know performing up in
front of a group a big group of people
that you don't know is scary and like
everyone is so brave for doing it but
not really because everyone in the
audience was so supportive there wasn't
act and act that didn't get a standing
ovation everyone was just like cheering
laughing if they needed to screaming if
they didn't if she was singing if they
needed to like literally the most
supportive audience like it made it not
scary like it wasn't a brave thing for
anyone to get up there and perform
because the audience you could have
farted and like I ran I mean like I
think some people do that 11 11 make a
wish I wish for days like this I wish
for happiness like this forever oh great
truly uh so some of the highlights
before we get to the winners of the town
show we had a live haircut on stage
which I don't think I will ever get over
no and I have to say it looks so good oh
it looks so good it was within the span
of one song they used scissors from the
office and a comb that they found on the
floor and they were both drunk and I
think like that really deserves an
honorable mention rude we had a couple
cheers we had the gay variety show again
this year they incorporated some audio
from my counselor snitch footage from my
Instagram which I just thought was so
premium and creative we had what we had
so much singing talent Whitney Houston
we had we had Fitness Easton I had
literally a live reenactment of the
entire play wizard a wicked he has
everybody sang songs from wicked we
Brent we really soo girl sing for good
like I let her had chills like I don't
know if they knew each other before
canisters oh well it made it seem like
liver they met through the toasts and
the song like I had been changed for
good like their lives wouldn't be the
same without each other and I was like
yes I was crying I was crying during
that song because every lerk was so
pertinent to cam ptosis like because I
knew you I have been changed for good
and like that was literally camp toast
and just to clear the air I asked
forgiveness for the things you blame me
for yeah but I guess there really
matters and he like literally chills
again when you look up the lyrics it's
literally the story of cam toasts and
they were so good like I was really just
impressed with how talented everyone was
and then creative however like how
creative everyone was my favorite types
of performances were the ones that took
like ordinary songs and turn them into
toasty songs so we had those two girls
who rewrote it's a hard-knock life -
it's a toaster life and it was just so
premium they posted the lyrics in the
camp trust to Europe and I was just
reading them last night and they missed
like so many of their I missed so much
and it was so good and we all need to
learn the song for next year yeah then
we had Chloe doing an original cheer
from bringing on yes she did the bring
it on chair but made it all Toshi so it
was like I'm I'm toasty I'm kid I don't
remember but like it was really good
yeah it was really good oh so we had
like two girls tapped hand saying - how
many [ __ ] do I give which is so
beautiful it just it was art art like
there was just so many acts like that
that were just so creative great song
choice of songs cat obviously did it had
Montana medley full wig dress and all
and I thought that I would have to like
really push people to sign up for the
town show because I was being miss
darbus with the list and I'm like at
lunch I will be taking signups and if
you are not signing up like I will come
peer pressure you know and literally I
was being stormed at the best deal at
lunch like literally everyone wanted it
I'm a big town show know a hundred
percent we have Kyle and his heels oh my
god he did the entire Senate latest
dance and probably the highest sales
I've ever seen and I was so shocked that
like he didn't break his ankle shocked
it was like it was crazy to watch and
like of course you know I got into
grandma mode where I was like yes he's
beautiful out there he survived you did
um and then of course we had our big
winners which was H for her starring
Hannah Lou bleh
they did a dance to one of the lizzo
songs that I did their truth hurts and
then Hannah Lube like came out as Liz oh
and I swear literally a million people
jammy thinking it was actually Liz oh
she was incredible that's how can
since you could send all the backup
dancers were just so great everyone was
twerking there was a girl more I don't
know if you met her but she was just
like an amazing dancer she was out there
front and center English so everyone
knows how to targeted the splits and
like Oh Joan and I didn't get that scam
yeah in life all I can do is kick line
and break my neck yeah um and it was
just like incredible we had Olivia try
singing only hope oh wait her room two
tears which brought the room to tears
and she was after Hannah Montana so we
went from such a crazy like ray I was
gonna tell service I was gonna say
honestly like judge do it like you can't
be bigger and better than Hannah Montana
like the room lit the [ __ ] off for
Hannah Montana and I was like Olivia
like you're gonna embarrass yourself
with your sad song like maybe just cut
it out with your sad like cuz it was a
downer I was like how is everyone gonna
get on their feet for this she comes on
everyone's flashlight on their phones
she had the biggest standing ovation I
knew it was a popular song but I didn't
know everyone would know every single
word and it was just it was crazy
and she was only gonna be like we told
everyone like first verse and chorus
everyone did every single whole song
yeah but you know it was fine still we
got buddy in the after-party going out
in time ten you know who literally sat
in the talent show for another two hours
it was a three-hour town show and like
Theo was the judge and he slept by my
foot the whole time he was such a good
[ __ ] boy but I really like I never
wanted it to end like I was just loving
the crowd I was loving the support I was
loving the talent I was loving the
cheering that I was just loving it all I
was something you know when I was drunk
we had some military toasters there they
did a beer talking Highness we had five
total military toasters and like I was
such a pleasure and an honor to meet
them and on Memorial Day nonetheless and
if they chose to spend Memorial Day like
at camp that was truly like I had chills
and like when they said they were the
military toasters literally the crowd
went [ __ ] everyone was on their feet
doing a USA chant like that is what camp
Trust is all about and that is what the
morning shows is all about just having
respect for those who served in the
Armed Forces or serve in the Armed
Forces I was like that was probably like
one of the peaks in my weekend like just
that 10 seconds where the military
toasters were being so [ __ ] cute
chugging a beard to Luke Bryan song like
how America are we know and it's just
everyone respected the hell out of
military military now because I was in
the military and I was a proud toes mama
I was a proud toaster at that moment
like I just showed up with my hand on my
chest took my hat off and I was like
here
we also had a subgroup slam poetry Wow
one of the most creative they did at
like live reenactment of like five of
their favorite subgroups so it was hot
and toasty they had like an essay time
thing going on it was ste nice fifties
we had a mini Taylor Swift concert it
was booting the chest we had a beauty
tutorial happening we had deal and
friends where's Thea made an appearance
we had toast after dark where we eat
sharing a cup a box
it was CIA where they solved a case it
was actually like really fighting that
was like that was really cool because
that was like our weird online like
thing coming to life you know and I
think one of the most bravest talents
out there is some poetry to it they did
it and they crushed it and it was a
really United the group and it's like
that's really how we all met so it was a
full circle moment yes the groups to
life totally anything else any other on
row mentions we had the wizard and I
which won second place by Lauren
Elizabeth Temple who was a girl who fell
asleep in the grass it was premium
that's like there's nothing I can't stop
saying the word premium because it's
really the only thing that describes the
way I felt and the way what I saw
we had max Davenport and Renee doing an
reenactment of the American camper pack
with her mom and like and Renee was the
mom and they were like what do I pack
and Renee gave a jewel a thing of snacks
wet wipes wet wipes and that's really a
blanket and a bucket yeah and it's
really what you pack for this cameraman
oh thank you the thing about what's
right back for this camp is like even if
you don't pack the right things like
someone will have it
that's what's incredible camp back cam
totes like someone didn't even have a
pillow yeah Renee it literally drove up
she got a car top storage unit
she brought pillows blankets and sheets
for everyone who flew and couldn't bring
it with them and then when we left camp
yesterday I roll up to the office and
everyone's sheets pillow and blankets
are there I'm like what is that they're
like did anyone throw it out they asked
us if we could donate it
Taylor Puzo took home a trunk full of
pillows blankets sheets and stuff to
give to a drive at her son school or
daughter I don't remember
um son child child yeah I don't see
gender actually so whatever and then
everyone else who had their sheets and
pillows and stuff that they didn't take
home with them they didn't want to throw
it out
so they literally brought it to the
office and they're gonna donate it to a
local like organization like how special
it's like even when they're at their
peak drunk and crazy it's like the
Chosin remember
giving that and they're not wasteful
Katie Pastore is making announcement you
know for mother earth to stop littering
yeah you for that by the way the grounds
thank you
also I just want to make it an honorable
mention too we had the game of thumb
Thrones theme song on the record or than
the recorder really brought me back to
my elementary school days and like
that's [ __ ] Talent yeah so there was
no shortage of talent the town show was
really so [ __ ] crazy everyone who was
in the room Weezer like worked there was
like a bartender or just you know wasn't
a camp toaster was like shook to the
[ __ ] and they don't even
understand like the slam poetry like
they don't get that but like they were
just like loving the camaraderie yes
exactly it's so funny because last year
when we threw our first camp trust we
were driving up and we were like this
was a terrible idea like we'll do it
once we'll make it great and we aren't
never doing it again then the weekend
went so well we were like oh my god
we're gonna do it every year and then
this year as we were driving up we had
to pit again because it was so many
people and we're like this is gonna be
[ __ ] show like let's just stop here yeah
never do it again
but and now I'm like I can't wait
another year to do it again
I know it's and I'm thinking of all the
ways I want to improve yeah okay so what
would you do different leads we should
do anything differently this year or you
just want to add things no I just want
to add things and my goal and I know
it's crazy and it might not happen and I
hate saying things if it's not gonna
happen I don't think it's that crazy I
don't think it's that crazy either but
like I want to get a performer like a
real performer like I know it'll cost
money but we like we will figure it out
maybe get like a sponsor in there I want
I really like my dream like I want Luke
Combs yeah that's my dream cake is that
so the camp toast vibe it's like a
really it's a country crowd um every
time they played a loop comb song like
the crab a [ __ ] while Jackie snapped
her neck and so her go bari so I don't
know how we can make it happen
financially I know we could make it
happen logistical aquino is manager we
know Cappy like we could figure it out
but the money thing is what um you know
like just Luke fly private I don't know
you know we should plan some seats now
because like we have a year like you
know I maybe we can do it and you know
maybe doesn't have to be Luke Holmes
like there are so many country artists
who when they like some of them saw
videos like either cuz you tagged them
are you sent is them like their songs
playing at campus basically Casey we
posted our chem toast story on her story
you send Kelsey the legends videos sang
Kelsea Ballerini the video of everyone
of the pool being wasted
legends and it's like I think it's just
one artist like saw that maybe they
would like figure out how to get there
no I know it has meaning someone's
playing in the area like you know like
yours like connected to a you know like
a huge country music star like please
let us know like I really wanna make it
happen like we'd set up a huge change on
the field I mean literally would be a
rave almighty like Luke should be there
cuz like Nico needs to be I cam to us
like a [ __ ] camp right now what
copper ticket in exchange for a
performance you know Luke is like my
dream and I feel like maybe he's like a
3-year dream yeah but like I would get
with someone smaller like I just think
having a performer that's like I love
the bugging me and Pentium yes yes I'm
looking at his record across the room
right now that would rank me we could do
it we could do it we need to hit up his
publicist yeah it's a record label they
know they're watching and I'm sure
they've got some ideas brewing like yeah
like if maybe like we get a Pepsi Pepsi
cuz to come in as a sponsor and I pay
for the whole thing and like give out
free Pepsi like I know that's like a
pipe dream but like but I was telling
bed about the event and like beddin
works in digital he works with brands he
like does events and I was showing him
like I was like up all night like
showing him all my pictures like a kid
who really just got home from camp and I
was like look at the hata check there's
1,100 pictures in that shot he was
floored he's like 1,100 you GCS and I'm
like what's that
is it user generated content that's such
a big deal in feed post that means every
person posted an average of 5 times he's
like explains make the business and he
was like that like any friend would like
die to be a part of that and I'm like I
know like give me one totally
I know I agree that's my dream Iran's an
artists I would just like beef up the
the activities a little bit more like
for the carnival which was lit I wish
he's got like a calm candy and popcorn
Stan like maybe a face painter well he
has like something I think we could have
done yeah so next time everything will
be like a beta every year you just like
keep improving oh what if we there could
change perform oh my god that would be
[ __ ] actually I think we might be
able to do that because
ShoeDazzle is a sponsor of this show and
ShoeDazzle is a partner of Erika Jayne
so we can get a ShoeDazzle sponsor
Darren yeah and everyone would be
running around there are coding shoes oh
my god I would love that that's a good
idea
okay they'll be wearing their thread up
threads and they're Erika Jayne shoes
oh yes that's epic that's what more
could you want well here's here's a
little more about thread up imagine
driving into the biggest closet in the
world pack with your favorite brands and
styles and unbelievable prices did you
know fashion is a second most polluting
industry in the world that's why we love
shopping second hand at thread up
choosing used clothes gives us second
life and keeps one less item from ending
up in the trash and that's a really big
deal we love shopping shopping but we
really do love the planet more if that's
why we go camping let's see here
and that's why we shop secondhand to
thread up whatever we feel like going on
a spree we get our dream wardrobe for a
fraction of the price and we're keeping
items out of landfills choosing to use
thread up it means guilt free shopping
there's still like a little bit of guilt
in love like with the whole money thing
but you know what I'm figuring it out
like and thread up is keeping our vistas
beautiful right and that's when when I
go to camp and I look around at these
beautiful grounds I'm like this is why I
shop at thredUP also I get like a fancy
designer bag for like a literally less
than half the price that helps to you
know thread up as a world's largest
online consignment and thrift store with
up to 90 percent off on estimated retail
prices they had over 50,000 new items
every day at unbeatable prices shop all
your favorite brands right now for the
comfort of your couch made well from
just nine dollars and apology from 13
Nike from 6 dollars everything is hand
inspected in triple checks to ensure
it's high-quality condition so that
makes it super easy to shop you can
customize your experience to see only
items in your size style and price range
visit thredUP comm slash toast today for
an extra 30% off your first order
that's thre d you p.com slash toast for
30% off your order
there's no a in there thr 8d you pee
comm / toast an extra 30% off today love
it don't forget terms apply and yes I'm
looking at the comments now we have
someone who works for Pepsi who's like
working on yes and people next year I'm
working in Memorial Day weekend again
yes I already reserved the campgrounds
with Jen before I left because it's just
it's great to have an extra day and
there's for travel for prices people
left at 11 a.m. so a lot of people got
home by like 4 or 5 o'clock if they
drove and that's a nice time to get home
relax
have dinner shower unpack like get
everything you need to get done and then
start your Tuesday off with on a clean
hangover free spray a little sore if you
plan it right you don't need to take off
any work and you know that's good cuz
you got to work because you got to go to
camp another note is and we had them and
I've we forgot to hand them out his name
tags yeah we're just we were just so
excited that let me forgot to give but
someone brought nametags they're like a
bunch of people were running around with
them but we should hand out nametags we
need a performer beefed up the carnival
and then I'm I have a little something
else extra but I don't want so yeah and
some of it will still be like surprises
like everything else but no overall it
was just incredible and of course like
you know we love camp and we could have
just sat on a pile of dirt on the side
of the road which is what we didn't had
a good time but like it would have have
been anything of what it was without the
toasters and their [ __ ] infectious
energy yeah like there were so many
people there and Elena would be good
sorry Lauren Elena would be literally
any much I'm a DJ I think that actually
could Manco ha lingo lamb Co you guys if
you haven't listened to Halloween how
much does it cost
I don't name you yeah we need like a
package we need to get a package shout
it's like when you have someone perform
at your wedding like people get people
to perform at their bar mitzvahs all the
time right and like Beyonce's $2,000,000
like who could we get for like a couple
Gees yeah a couple Gees and UGC and you
just see an I the way the 11-hundred
post i'll remind me is doesn't even
count stories and it doesn't have people
who are private no it does not mhm
that's so [ __ ] crazy the can post flow
is poppin and everyone use Jackie loves
everyone use Jackie about to see
something nice Oh about the toaster yeah
that like we could you know the scenes
we can do whatever like sit on the side
of the road and have a good time but
like cantos was what it was because of
the energy of the toasters there were so
many people who's just attitudes even
when they just showed up off the bus
like off the plane just bringing of
those treacherous to have travel like
just bringing so much positivity and
like that's what made camp what it was
like everyone was just there everyone
was open everyone was nice everyone was
friendly and just like down to have a
good time and down to experience new
things and meet new people and like I
mean just one name just keeps coming to
mind and it's max Davenport oh yeah
obviously kept it like the most positive
time from Alaska came from [ __ ] alone
alone and was he which award was color
world won best attitude he was a color
war general and like he just like made
camp even greater than when it wasn't
like there were so many people just like
that who I just can't thank them enough
for bringing everything they brought to
you yeah Kemp is what you make it
because at the end of the day you're in
a field with a tiny bunk but like camp
is what you make it and it was so lit
literally just because of the toasters
and everyone like at certain points are
the weekend we're like standing up and
just being like thank you Jackie and
Claudia for like making this community
and it's like I can't explain like how
much like the community has nothing to
do with us like people like you made
such a great community
it's like people just showed up and like
one it's me nice to each other like so
it's a campus when you make it and the
toaster community is what you make it
and every single toaster was so nice so
kind shared their clothes shared their
color graphics shared their wasn't even
like mean competition at color we're
like it's like everyone was just so
happy to be spending their Memorial Day
weekend like getting drunk in the Sun
and like being toasty right and even
once they showed up like yeah you could
have like sucked late drank laid by the
pool like did nothing and I'm sure some
people didn't had a great time like for
the people who like God well who like
God involved who went walking around the
camp to go to the jungle course or like
do waterfront activities that they like
weren't going to do like for that I
thank you for just doing trying
something new and taking a chance on
some unknown Steen's like right I will
never not like I don't think I will ever
get over like looking around the rec
hall seeing 250 people like singing only
hope and like just Hannah Montana and
being seen in like this is our dream
like if it were up to us we would like
go back to camp every single summer but
like we have to work and like you know
be with our husband sometimes it's
something not appropriate right so the
fact that we get to do this and that you
guys want to do this with us and are
having as much if not more fun than us
and like it's your dream to like is a
[ __ ] dream come true for us and like
cantos will never not be the pinnacle of
everything we ever worked towards in our
lives if you have a question let's do
like a quick Q&A if you have a question
on the YouTube stream drop it and we
will get to it because a lot of people
wanted to know like how much did camp
cost when are we doing it again is it
gonna be more a weekend every year so if
you have any logistical questions what
do you get with your ticket like oh yeah
just logistical questions and drop it in
the in double YouTube livestream and
we'll do our best to answer it for those
who wonder know what you guys with your
ticket obviously you get open bar open
food snacks board you got a free Camco
shirt and you get a free cam to ass
water bottle you get memories that will
last a lifetime it's really nice four
days of pure fun in the sound
adulterated fun Oh Jackie when were you
Academy I'll be back available um soon
ish I have a really busy week coming up
because like I'm leaving for Colgate
bringing in on Thursday so maybe not
till after that sorry umm this is a good
question if I won't be 21 at the time
tickets go on sale but I will be at the
time of camp can I still buy the tickets
yes all you to do is be 21 at camp
how did do do with all the campers he
was great honestly he was
little standoffish I would say just
because like he's such a big summer game
you know he if he starts embracing one
person like then the flock will follow
but I think he did well he needed to
keep his own mental health like at bay
and I think it worked out forever and I
saw some people I got some cute pictures
with him but it wasn't like everywhere
with everyone like licking everyone's
toes do you get to pick your bunk mates
you get to request your bunk mates
and then we make bunks based off of your
recommendations but like if if you
request eight people and those request
other eight people obviously you all
can't be in the same bunk together so
yeah you will definitely be with at
least one person that you request a
bunch of people is it gonna be Memorial
Day weekend every year at least next
year yeah I'm loving the three-day
weekend too and also like I hit Memorial
Day there's nothing to do and like it's
there no one ever has good plans like
what's better than hanging out with my
toes for friends and get a drunk and
it's a great time of year because the
weather was really nice but the nights
got really cold so you're not sweating
in your sleep and there was only one day
that I sweat in and that was when I was
doing the ropes course so I think the
weather was most ideal for this set of
people does each bunk have their own
bathroom
yes can it be 18 and over no where is
camp DOS I'm from Michigan it's in the
Pocono Mountains in Poconos Pennsylvania
and it's actually a lot easier to get to
than you would think there's only about
like 10 minutes of like backwoods
driving the rest is all highways are the
activities extra I think she means money
like to me the ropes course no it's a
flat fee oh this is good questions did
you have kosher catering so a lot of
people were concerned that they wouldn't
be able to keep Shabbos and we had to
halitosis Shira and her sister who came
totally prepared they showed up right
before Shabbat started they brought the
kosher kid the catering company had
brought them closer wine they did Friday
night services cuz they brought their
own caller they brought their own
candles they brought their own food in
the kitchen staff heated it up for them
like made arrangements as much as they
could so they brought all their own
stuff and I was reading a thread today
and they in the toasters and they had a
premium experience they said it was
easy-peasy they had no complaints and
that I thought was really cool so while
camp isn't technically kosher or
Strummer Shabbos you can be shomer
Shabbos and kosher they gave me a piece
of their challah and it was so delicious
can we get a morning bugle player to
wake us up in the morning Parent Trap
style we need to teach Margot how to
play the bugle
well yeah that's our
solution can anyone drive up do you need
to take the transportation no people
drove up people uber people took a bus
people took a train like berry there's a
parking lot you can meet your car yes
how do the bunks work like how did you
set up putting people in bunks um based
on requests and then just taking some
like creative liberties based on where
people are from people's ages you know
interests what we can glean from
Facebook if people didn't request anyone
but at the end of the day like if you're
a toaster you have at least one thing in
common and you can really bunk with
anyone you know there's so much like
you're not just like with your bunk the
whole time like and by the way you could
get into a bunk and you get there and
you're like these aren't my people you
can use bunks and we left like two or
three extra beds open and every bunk so
people have the ability to move around
and people did they just took it upon
themselves to move because reminder it
is not breathing right I kept having to
tell people that yeah since previous
campers get first dibs how likely can a
new freshman camper get tickets um only
patreon members get first dibs so you
have just as good a chance as anyone and
you know what tickets didn't sell out
this time for a month that's when they
sold out so um that I would say you have
at least a few weeks to get your ticket
and then even towards the end there were
a few tickets opening up so just if you
really want to go like keep tabs on it
and you'll get your spot are you going
to or become a patron member and that's
the best a lot of people are wanting to
know why it is an 18 and over because
it's open bar there's no way we're not
gonna card people that will slow down
the bar process and so we just can't
have people under 21 there because
there's just too much proximity to
alcohol and like we have enough going on
that we don't need to worry about that
as well so I'm sorry to toaster stay in
a bunk with you guys our bunk was full
our bunk was full and between sisters
Margo and Jay and Kristen Margo and
Kristen are toasters so yes just yes we
did and you know what you know who is
the biggest toaster of the weekend
snitch she's out there being a toaster
she was a camper every night she was
building the cabin to bed at like 12:30
1:00 and she wasn't in her bed yet she
was like out party every night we were
like waiting for Fitch to get back she
was hanging out with her home friends
the senior um how many people were there
total to 15 D can you tell us more about
the transportation from NYC you can get
there however you want yeah there's a
lot of different ways except - it's what
is it 85 miles
yeah it's depending on what time you
leave it really the drive is an hour and
a half two hours from the city um a lot
of people carpooled with other toasters
that they had never met
you there is a bus that you can take
from Port Authority that gets you to
Mount Pocono / Stroudsburg and from
there it's a quick cab there's a ton of
different ways you can also take a mean
it's expensive but if you share with
enough toasters you could do BER yeah if
you can get enough toasters into five
people yes yeah can you talk about the
vegetarian options because I was
actually really impressed so every day
there was a huge salad bar at every meal
but then every meal also had a veggie
option so like when it was like barbeque
night there was I picked up I thought it
was chicken it was tofu oh yeah there's
tofu I eat vegetarian neck salmon eat
non-kosher meat so there was one night
there was a stuffed portobello mushroom
that was divine it was a capricious
fellow who one night one day was tacos
there was fake taco meat that was uh
what's that called Satan no um yes sir
take me I sit down no I'm thinking of a
different word okay uh I forgot
impressionists meat or impostor meat
something like that um anyways there was
more than enough vegetarian options as a
vegetarian at camp when little tickets
go on sale December again yeah before
the holidays so you can get them to
someone is there places to go if you
have a medical issue I have social
anxiety and I'm worried about going yes
actually when we were driving first of
all there's a nurse on on the grounds um
and doctor fan yes but when we were in
camp as kids there wasn't a hospital
nearby and so that you have to drive so
far to a hospital but in town there's a
brand new it stunning hospital yeah
what's the age range of people camp er
so we have anyone from 21 to 53 no but
we could go
there's no too old for camp some people
are like I want to come but I'm too old
there is no such thing as being too old
for camp but yes there is such thing as
being too young can I do my bachelorette
party there next year that is great I
would yeah crazy yes oh my god I love
that idea
me too birthday parties bachelorette
parties we do everything divorce parties
I'm a super late sleeper so that I'm one
reason I didn't go is sleeping in a room
with a million people so um there
because we don't fill up the whole camp
there are in xx a bunk so I know there
were a few people who had their own
bunks if you wanted your own bunks there
was a girl I think she had sleep apnea
she wanted her own bunk you can have
your own bunk if you need one also
people asked if they could bring their
husbands and yeah technically you and
your husband could come and have
bunk I would just say if you ask the
people who came like it was nice for
them to be away from their husbands and
really get involved with the girls but
husbands are welcome we did not have any
husbands or straight men this year but
they they are welcome to comment yes
okay so that was fun I like don't know
if I will ever stop talking about camp
DOS but probably not yeah someone else
if we would ever have an all-ages event
we could if we didn't have an open bar
situation and you would have to fight
the toasters right look I think at this
point I would rather like exclude
certain people just so we get alcohol
right because it's just a safety issue
like as much as this is all fun like
this is very like we have people's lives
in our hands right like taking on this
event is a huge undertaking I'm like it
really is a lot of responsibility and
that's why like there's a lot of
legality involved when you add alcohol
on top of all of it like it just you
know we just have to be safe and we
can't have underage drinking so that's
why we have to put the kibosh yeah but
you know what hopefully will be doing
cam to us for a while and so your turn
will come exactly
well once again thank you to every
tester who really came in made this
weekend what it was it was so fun like I
really had the best time I can't wait to
do it again I'm already like thinking of
ideas for next year if you work at like
a record label or a brand or like
someone who can help us get a performer
this year like please I'm just like ass
believe received manifest destiny like
putting it out there like hopefully next
year like we will be rocking out to Lou
combs at camp tell us like that would be
[ __ ] crazy that would be [ __ ]
crazy yeah I can't even think about it
anyways we it's gonna be a busy week we
have merch coming your way
stay tuned on Thursday we are here for
all people campers just keep posting on
Facebook check in the crew cantos group
first time updates if you didn't get
your merch at and so jackie is our
Colgate reunion on Friday so we are here
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday this week and
my clan I could really use a Friday off
and I am home for the weekend for the
first time since February and I don't
know what to do I feel like I'm gonna be
bored what's crazy is I like have
looking like I've been more excited for
a reunion than I was for my own wedding
and then I even was for cam toast and
it's like the fact that reunion is going
to be crazier than both of those things
I'm honestly scared you need to drink
some liquid I think I need to drink some
liquid IV I'm s hi
this week and just like also I have to
go to uni and like I'm it's five years
later I got a stunt on these hoes as
well so like I need to like lose five
pounds like the stunting on the house is
definitely like a huge undertaking it's
a huge undertaking so I have to get my
[ __ ] together like definitely physically
etc but you know I'm just living on a
high from campus I'm gonna go home and
lay on my phone well I'm gonna put
together a video but also I just
watching stories like that should I pay
for home oh right but that's what I did
all day yesterday Zach was like t11 she
gave me throw-in suck him in again I
think now I have to watch on cam to
escape if I got home at 5:30 and a
shower to run pack tag on to bed at 6:30
and I did not get off my phone and even
turned the TV on I did not get off my
phone until midnight because there was
so little service at camp there like I
haven't been on my phone in four days
and I didn't get to see I wanted to like
every single person's picture who use
hashtag ham chill and you have to watch
stories before they expire right also I
added all of our cam shows stories to
highlight the highlights also did you
know I didn't even know there's a limit
on how many highlights you're in 100 so
we have two of a hundred each that's
crazy the the stories were premium like
literally the whole talent show is on
stories the most is color war etc we can
go relive over and over again until the
patreon video comes out that's gonna be
really sweet you know obviously I'll get
there behind the scenes but also we have
some personal moments from some of our
campers yes we do testimonials of people
who had been to camp before new campers
I'm just seeing like what their their
expectations were like where they have a
period of time I said I was a filmmaker
I said be honest just pretend like I'm
not here
totally so anyways before we go I just
want to thank Pocono Valley Resort and
the entire staff there they did an
incredible job howard Genscher show we
just love you and we love being there
and thank you for making camp oh yeah
epic Frogtown Chop House who are our
caterers our hype men you know who kept
the toasters toast - yes thank you so
much if you ever in the Poconos check
them out a confetti wine brand new brand
they just launched they launched at camp
trust which i think is so cool and like
a great business move on their part so
make sure to support confetti wine check
your local uh liquor store I know you
spend a lot of time there and just the
toasters everyone from you know the MVPs
and the Award winners to Township
winners just the people who were there
cheering who are equally as important
because what's fun to perform to an
empty exactly so thank you to everyone
thank you sister for being a wonderful
business partner
sister for just you know going on this
adventure with me yes we will see you
next year [ __ ] and we will also see
you tomorrow
yeah
you